hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video spielen heute das spiel des teams
vorher war ihr findet ihr links schon
das logo eingeblendet
so sieht das aus und das sap logos das
hier also mit seinem komischen fähig und
was der isst und was wir darin machen
müssen zeige ich euch jetzt so sieht das
ganze game hier quasi erst mal menü aus
also wir haben wir verschiedene welten
das geht doch unendlich weiter als ihr
gibt es noch frost hügel schattig geheim
was haben wir hier dunkler sand und es
geht so was von lang weiter hier seht es
geht bis 15 der beute ballon und ich bin
gerade glaube ich bei drei oder so das
ist auf jeden fall neue spielen der best
finns trilogie also sind quasi dieselben
charaktere dabei und die story und
geschichte ist relativ ähnlich
allerdings ist eine komplett neue art
des spiels um zusammen zu fassen das ist
ein click abenteuer spiel man muss alles
möglich einsammeln und sich hochleveln
und kann coins einsammeln und gegner
besiegen und so weiter und so fort und
ihr findet schon in irgendeiner ecke
werbe video eingeblendet ich hab das sie
einmal sehr transparent mit euch was
wirklich so bezahlte sachen angeht und
zwar haben die mich einfach gefragt ob
ich das game zocken möchte vor zugang
und deswegen muss ich halt als
werbevideo kennzeichnen hier findet auch
in der beschreibung ein download-link
eingeblendet aber wir schauen jetzt erst
mal wo ich bin und zwar habe ich die
ersten beiden wirklich schon fertig
gekriegt das ist rumpel berg und die
grünen licht und das war noch relativ
easy und jetzt muss ich sturms höhle
machen legt einfach mal auf weiter und
dann seht ihr schon bin ich hier drin
dass hier unten ist mein team und was
ich quasi machen muss es den typen da
besiegen und da kommen halt voll viele
von diesen schwarzen teilen und die
bewachen quasi vielleicht soll ich euch
das spiel erstmal erklären um es euch
wirklich mal richtig zu erklären da das
spiel ist nicht best friends forever
sondern bestens forever und da sind zum
monster die sind schwarz und die halten
meine freunde quasi gefangen und ich
muss immer durch voll viele
monsterwellen mich durchkämpfen
um in diesen finalen kampf reinzukommen
und quasi eine neue person aus meiner
bande zu befreien
ich habe hier unten schon fünf leute
befreit also ich habe diesen maikäfer
dieses gelbe dingen dieses grüne ding
diese komische fliege und dieses was
auch immer das für ein ding ist ich habe
27 63 b also bild
johnen glaube ich jetzt eher nicht
milliarden millionen irgendwie so münzen
und kann damit meine leute jetzt die
hochleveln also ihr seht schon hier
unten habe ich quasi drauf klicken und
dann level ich die hoch und das heißt
sie werden stärker und ich kann die
schneller einsetzen und so das heißt ich
verfalle jetzt mal mein ganzes cash ihr
ein ab jetzt nur noch 61 millionen
points und klick jetzt mal aufschlage
dem box bzw gehe jetzt direkt in den box
kampf an und ihr seht schon oben das ist
jetzt relativ easy den typen zu besiegen
weil ich meine leute gerade mega hoch
gelegt habe habe ihn jetzt besiegt und
kann jetzt hier auf die box klicken und
habe jetzt schien eugene crepes von
spongebob denn tape bin ich auf klasse
mit freigeschaltet wir gerade gesehen
hatten schaden von 600.000 und jetzt
habe ich die sturm höhle besiegt und bin
jetzt in schleckheim falls ihr euch
übrigens fragt wieso ich das zocken und
ihr das vielleicht nicht im app store
findet das kommt eigentlich erst am
samstag raus also am 22
nur ein paar youtuber die da halt mit
dem spielehersteller kooperieren haben
quasi sondern vorab zugang erhalten aber
ihr könnt es quasi ab dem 22
zehnter also ab dem samstag jetzt im app
store und dem google places runterladen
vor die braut sich ein riesiges portal
zusammen vielleicht hat das alles
endlich ein ende wenn du hindurch gehst
auf geht's so sieht das quasi aus also
wir haben hier rechts links überall
schätze des seht ihr schon da kann ich
drauf klicken und hier halten uns war
diese leute davon ab diese schätze zu
bekommen zb da oben rechts ist ein
schatz hier unten ist ein schatz sind
damit schon angeklickt zwischendurch
werden noch teilweise so
röhren freigeschaltet sage ich mal ihr
seht schon ich habe das spiel wirklich
schon sehr lange gespielt zwischendurch
werden so röhren freigeschaltet oder so
explosionen und mit denen gibt's an
solche zusatz dinge beispielsweise bei
den röhren kann ich dann irgendwohin
checken und da extra münzen bekommen die
explosion erklären sich quasi von selbst
also wenn ich auf das fast mit einem tnt
drin drauf clique dann ja geht das ding
halt in die luft und helfen mir ein
bisschen die leute hier zu besiegen das
geht jetzt hier alles noch recht langsam
ich kann aber ganz kurz die die leute so
ein bisschen hochleveln und ihn ja zum
beispiel hochziehen habe ich mich ein
auto schlag drin hier feuerbälle und ihr
geld und ihr seht schon wie ich jetzt
die durch hassel also hier zeigt durch
das portal hier die nächsten von rechts
kommen vorteile dieser gelbe gibt mir
ein extra colin buß deswegen regnete die
ganze irgendwelche coins es ist aber
eigentlich gut wenn man sich so die
krassen attacken von den leuten also ein
auto schlag hier die kann ich die ganze
zeit eigentlich reinpacken also der
steht jetzt quasi für mich dass ich da
nicht die ganze draufklicken muss das
ist ganz gut sich die sachen fürs ende
aufzubewahren zum beispiel den
donnerschlag jetzt warm der typ ist tot
und damit habe ich derzeit geschafft ich
nehme den typen in der mitte bekomme 259
millionen münzen und ihr seht schon es
ist wirklich mega easy an coins
ranzukommen ich kann hier vor die jetzt
auf was einsammeln und zwar habe ich
spiele zwei stunden lang nicht mehr seht
ihr schon ich habe zwei stunden lang
nicht gespielt kann dass die einsamen
diesen ganzen anderen sachen was ich
schon alles erreicht habe in dem game
wird schon echt sagen ich bin bisher der
beste spieler das game ist natürlich
auch noch nicht offiziell draußen aber
hey ich will mal als bonus eine billion
münzen so vor ort beziehungsweise eine
milliarde das ist ja glaub ich dann
level ich meine leute hier noch mal so
ein bisschen hoch und ihr seht schon man
kriegt zwar relativ schnell münzen also
ich kann jetzt ein auto schlag
aktivieren und die vorteile und ihr seht
schon wenn ihr mal oben auf die münzen
achtet da die ganze zeit ist das schnell
wirklich hoch wie viele millionen münzen
ich dachte hier allein jetzt sieben
monaten millionen alter aber die teile
sind halt auch teuer ihr seht zum
beispiel unten
links der typ kostet nicht 600 millionen
um ihn hoch zu level das heißt ich legte
einmal drauf habe ich nur noch 200
millionen münzen ich könnte stundenlang
wirklich über dieses spiel aber ich weiß
nicht wie lange dieses video ist weil
ich die ganze zeit drauf clique als man
will wirklich gern zeit drauf klicken
will die neuen leute hier hochziehen
dass ich ein auto schlag mit am start
habe wieder ganz viele münzen bekommen
bin jetzt gleich bei einer b münzen
wieder genau level die leute hier mal
wieder so ein bisschen hoch und jetzt
sich beispielsweise in ihr hoch ab jetzt
feuerbilder die von links und rechts
überall reingeschossen kommen ja auch
die bösen leute da vor allem an ihrer
oder das war gerade richtig kurz vor ich
klappt zusammen weil ich keine luft mehr
habe ich würde eigentlich der noch den
bosskampf vier am ende hin kriegen weil
ich mich echt frage wie krass da sein
wird also ich denke ich spiele jetzt mal
ein bisschen vor bis zum boxkampf
so wir sind jetzt in einem bosskampf
angekommen ich ziehe jetzt mal den
feuerball hier nach oben jeden maikäfer
links und nochmal den auto schlag und
dann müssten das denke ich hin kriegen
den tiefen der zeit zum 7 bord nein
freunde es wird richtig eng alter ohne
spaß der mega guter schafft ja safe
nicht alter schwede
ja wahrscheinlich nicht geschafft das
was ihr von dem video meine damen und
herren ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
ist jetzt natürlich blöd dass ich am
ende extra time labs gemacht haben extra
abgezockt zum bus zu kommen und dann
einfach abgekratzt bin aber wie gesagt
ich zog das geld jetzt wirklich schon
seit 23 tagen rund um die uhr also check
das spiel auf jeden fall mal ab ist es
kostenlos wie gesagt der download links
und in der infobox treibt mir mal in die
kommentare weitergekommen wird des games
ja jetzt quasi heute draußen ab dem 22
ich habe war wohl wo sich denn hier mein
level also meine derzeitige phase 65 und
ich habe gesamte einnahmen von 34 b also
von tieren 30 milliarden münzen und
meine euro bei der spielzeit ist
zweieinhalb tage aber meine aktive zeit
in der app sind dreieinhalb stunden und
damit beende ich jetzt auch das video
haut rein danke an die entwickler dass
ich das vorher spielen durfte und das
video das sie das unterstützt haben und
bisher uns freunde